so again every recursive proof starts
with something
and then we've got to go all right how
do we get to the next one okay what I'm
going to suggest is you go look at the
previous term and then add on that
number of the term that you're on okay
so
like we did before and I'm going to get
my red color out just so we can show you
right
um
a question you guys would get in an exam
or in textbook or that kind of thing
within the course we'll hand you the
explicit formula at this point and say
off you go start the proof by induction
but I wonder if we could work out what a
hypothesis an explicit formula might
look like
we already know what the first term is
and for reasons they're going to become
very clear in a second I hope I'm going
to draw this rather than just do the
algebra okay so here is term one it's
one
what's term two going to look like
I'm going to add two on right sorry
so there there is term two I need a new
color
[Applause]
you're cheating this you already you
know too much math no that's mine that's
okay well right okay term three I've got
to start with temp two which looks like
this
and then I've got to add on the N right
that's what gets me to the next term
which in this case is
three
okay now
the numbers are one and then three and
then six they are called the triangle
numbers because
hopefully self-evident okay but now I
want you to have a think well how might
I work out a formula for this
um there now that you guys are in your
12 properly you actually know more than
one way to work out like the area of a
triangle that's what we're trying to
calculate right what are the two main
ways that you know to work out every
triangle
half base times height this is the one
you learned a long time ago what's the
other way
okay so we could go we go all the way to
yeah yeah it's it's half it's still half
then you've got to look at the other two
sides and then you've got to say oh I've
got to relate them in some way if
they're not like right angled and that
kind of thing right now I'm just going
to suggest cool but slightly overpowered
for this right I've got nice like right
angled looking things right so the half
base height formula it comes from the
fact that every triangle is half of a
rectangle or a square I mean a square is
a rectangle that fits around it right
so what would be the other half what
would it look like well in this case
like can you imagine
here's the half of a rectangle does that
make sense this is the whole rectangle
now and this is the half that I want
this would be half of
that rectangle do you agree
what are the dimensions of these
rectangles
this one's three
by two and this one is four
by three
you've seen a pattern okay help me help
me to articulate this now right because
what I really want to get to and I want
to get to an end some some generalized
version right so what's the relationship
between like what where do you see
numbers from these things coming from
from here
very good right so here's the n
which there's three there's two
this is always one more than that right
so this is the n plus one
and this is the n plus one okay
so my hypothesis is my half base height
is for term n it's half
my base or I mean I guess algebraically
would be nice to put this one first
right here's um an n and then my other
dimension will be n plus one that is an
explicit formula can you see it doesn't
depend on the previous terms right so
like I said before ordinarily the
question would say Okay recursive
formula explicit formula off you go can
you see why like I I think this is
actually the part that's we're doing
some mathematics to think and try and
work out like I what I always got
crossword whenever I did push by
induction I was like wait a second but
you already know this is true otherwise
you wouldn't have handed to me as a
question why are you asking me to prove
it right it's like well it wasn't always
the case someone had to work this thing
out and then someone had to say okay on
my instincts right though can I can I
prove this rigorously using induction
right so I'm going to pause right there
it's like no I think the question's
wrong sir it's like it's like oh no have
I done something wrong on my exam I'm
gonna stop for a moment I'm sick to
death in the sound of my own voice and I
want you guys to have a have a whirl
um test assume proof and um call me ever
if you um have a suggestion or are
hitting a roadblock